yeah and welcome to Sunday night's live
show I hope some of you are around yet
on that somewhat unusual time we have
rescheduled the show from Monday to
Sunday just for once as we have the
rabbit and blitz part of the scene
filled Cup coming up starting tomorrow
and I won't compete with with Gary
Kasparov that doesn't make any sense
because Morrow was making a comeback in
the rapid part and then the Blitz part
of that event five days and yeah the
competition is a bit stiff they're
competing with Gaspar oh also I want to
watch myself this is clearly also point
so let's see what we can do I have fun
entered the 5-minute pool here on the
ICC and see what happens my mouse isn't
working all that great what's going on
here yeah but I don't get a game it's
the thing not there are quite a number
of title players on so I should get a
game but take the moment somehow
I have to check any good videos on the
ICC we are part 16 of my video series is
out about poor majorities yeah anyway
I'm waiting for again but it it's kind
of slower teams so hello to meat grinder
go on the Lockridge and add kappa henyk
in the chat you need a new one
this mouse is new actually
but somehow I have to get a jerk and
adjust the church anytime I can gain
started playing role that's funny so
this is here what's the name I like
reprint sir this is a disguise total
madman so off let's see what he does see
I'm playing the the Kings gambit he
played them
he also played one g4 not so this is
rather on the solid side Queen to e2
food ok so he 5 is probably what he
wants to do
maybe I played this anyway check maybe
this is actually a line now okay so take
care on Knight takes pawn takes probably
now this that looks actually very okay
for me I'm threatening to kill his pawn
structure but she does not really it
doesn't feel like it's awesome all that
much okay so creamy fight and met he was
asking am I going to do daily
five-minute blitz videos again I don't
know um it's certainly possible but it's
not something I have I have to something
that I've thought about that much
currently I'm quite happy with just
making some videos when I feel like it
and I don't want to do that daily grind
at the moment I like three games a day
okay what the heck okay so I can take
the Queen he takes my queen and I take
on g2 winces this is good for me there's
really nothing wrong with this approach
grabbing a pawn
this guy's totally crazy this is a good
rule it is a good move I didn't want him
to take the SD five was hanging
immediately okay so I was thinking B
five to completely kill off his bishop
so strategically speaking my position is
great but it is kind of weird still ok
so I thought this yam to keep this out I
mean he has a bishop on these three
which is essentially dead that is a cup
of lanka the bishop with that it has no
no scope at all night before and night
m4k i should be quick this is certainly
useful let's see right before i can also
go lookee to here right okay true so
rookie 294 maybe yes so sorry for
pouring water it could actually get to
that sudden urge of going to want it to
go to the bathroom okay anyway and
what's going on here maybe put this
I have friggin I wondered this is
nonsense no I that's you put night f-for
it just goes back
yeah that's terrible what was totally
lost before I mean like resign a ball
almost but now now is back in the game
and that was what was also a bad
decision should take me the night of
course and anyway I still have to play
this and let's see
so this I can also just approach with
the King for 285 he wants to go to a
five this is this is not not that clear
I always always hate to give away points
against display because he's a total
nutcase in terms of chess anyway let's
see what happens it's it's still not
totally clear if I wouldn't have
blundered d5 game pure already hitter I
did
and takes c3 next maybe it's it okay
d5 is an interesting check seeing nine
morning maybe I should actually move
this the knight on c3 is such a weird
position d6 f3
totally wacky
check
why is that it's that's so weird
everything check
not even this position is totally clear
check check I think I'm winning now
check check check check check
again Google drawn I would have a key
game it's ok so let's go for the next
one
yeah the modem the maintenance KNI I
spent much time being in this weird
position but if I don't blunder d5 the
game is just over 1 over 20 like here I
just blunder don't I don't blunder d5
it's just over it's got a debt which
game is restarted ok we shall overcome
let's get a win in against this ok place
the modern defense
one of the video opening names I think
what is modern today might be
old-fashioned tomorrow and they want to
call it the model okay let's see I'm
playing for central control here okay so
we should see six doesn't seem to be an
issue for him can also take him and
let's take check
57 he has to go fifty seven really Wow
so I check and then Queen Queen e2 is
hello to Lukesh no work check let's
check okay so look the one his plank
weeny seven and holds the stuff is that
unfair
so maybe this one it looks weird I know
yeah probably the ship c5 was was not
the best idea he's sort of he saved
himself from this terrible position
kingly services this is total nonsense
at Bishop takes e5 was a terrible move
probably probably
he still doesn't have everything in play
the root age 8 and so on so I don't have
the good discovery years that rule how
to live now this is this is now a bit
better for me at least maybe more than a
bit actually 95 and c3 as a beloved with
a new threat
check-check
okay so it's a very nice position being
a pawn up and having complete control a
form maybe and is a good night against a
pretty miserable Bishop now just for the
find this and now look you one comes
late I didn't have to do this also
further increase the control
[Music]
Oh gauge 6 and I can also take care ok
I have to check our hoop do you want as
possible
and again I think a number of most
probably win
trying to play g5 or just taking you 5
check night is covering the chicks or
just have six
yeah that's also a good move for oxy
seven so look see several warm
yeah or this way I think we're basically
all in check 95 there is no chicken a
giant check fortunately not check check
check
now I'm getting the Queen now all he has
to take check check check check
narcho plenty of time no need to be
hectic here check
the lack of memory damage no genders
please yeah this was a weird I mean he
really should not survive their opening
yeah but sticking on c5 feels pretty bad
just want to very quickly look at this I
don't either not touching this and he
shows but yeah yeah it was a bad idea
something probably just just a normal
move their plates he's got the key money
7 okay so next game who's on that some
title players around not sure early gas
will show up he played a and over the
board's tournament in in Riga the last
week and I know how he did I know that
he played a draw against Alex issue of
in one of the early rounds with black
and really having a header when I really
found that was a funny game because
Shiro simply traded down the whole board
which was so nice to to be stalling us
wants to trade everything okay I've got
a game request out there couple of good
five-minute players around but seems
like yeah Gary might come on for some
practice for tomorrow yes maybe that
would be fun but you don't know
England's toilet handle he has okay M
Fantozzi and toes he's got a good
waiting you go deeply okay check so we
got that get this luring him
and he's probably building some sort of
Hedgehog I decided to close it all down
okay after rook g1 I want to go to d4 it
seems okay Alice I'm going to play a
very very simple fashion so here both
board point vehicle just make sense okay
so do I want to go where for here in
this position or not I think I do
so I'm going to take and get the pawn
down or we'll get why f5 f5 is also
hmm it's all feels okay right
I determine all that good square to put
a term yeah I don't like it that I
shouldn't have played a five baby
yeah it's probably nothing special here
this belittle just feel some equality
maybe this idea to play f6 for me this
winning me some tempo and if he goes f6
now I go looks it to when I'm a bit
quick on the C file but he can maybe can
go he actually does that
yeah I thought f6 um I will play that it
cannot be cannot be bad now I'm
switching over that should be should be
OK for me
it feels risky what he's doing here
allowing at 6:00 I don't know I had very
easy attacking ideas rook a three-book f
1 2 3 and so on
hmm a bit weird I don't quite know what
to see what is he up to here
okay so just take this
it can hardly be bad after Queen age 6 I
also had a double attack on d6 and n
Duke but I still have this available so
just this move right so how do you win
this from you and five for h5 Luke g8
edges take and you cannot defend itself
I don't see how 87 is just collapsing
check Oh Oh interesting
g8
can everyone
check
you
I take is got Quincy aid and will take
on F severing it might win because I can
get d6 at the end but I think this is
winning immediately check walk to three
I can take with a pawn
between g8 as Queen f6 Luke g7 Luke FAA
twinning those are the great questions
how often do you shave with the Chang
every other day I think is probably
correct black resigns yeah so the lost
it was weird that was good to try which
it to what I think it does it does when
I have to go careful
okay so Winnie against Fantozzi who else
is on
now some good players not only bit game
started
I know a chestful not ask I've heard
Germans say one side has quality in a
position no this is actually this is
actually quality is the exchange
qualitative exchange hm in German
I've completely forgotten the area and
I've written a book on that Queen b6 is
a move and it's not terrible
oh really it's it looks very simplistic
just taking okay so do we
you can't keep the bishop I mean the
bishop pair is not that but I don't want
to weaken the dark squares that much now
it should be okay Bishop d6 58 okay so
we see playing some b5 stuff no but he's
preparing some b5 stuff so I probably
should go here okay a5 or what's the
deal I wants to take a day it takes each
five actually okay
yeah I still want to play that on the
queenside maybe it just takes that yeah
I wasn't really considering this only
takes on your fire cannot take only tool
I just got this root be one idea okay
now that's not good you didn't play this
well and yeah probably I should have
just gone to see serve on the air right
I mean that is very very unpromising
what you did just giving me the bishop
pair in the morning not in nothing
position a queen eight-six was probably
wrong
check now that's it's annoying check
okay yeah looks a bit shaky but I'm
still attacking still attacking stuff
before II - still not easy for what
95 maybe
I don't know with texting unfortunately
so I have a fly in the office like in my
last show really have to go hunting yeah
it did it next time before maybe is here
something nice yeah I don't know here
like be five or so some breakthrough no
doesn't
one step taken b7e to get rid of that
background issue i wants to go okay okay
eggs but there's one drawback
let's check check now so we took me ages
ages to see the small plate behind
fellows lucky i was really really in bad
shape
yeah clean eight six was bad i really
after the dead was that was far too
quickly plenty but just go here i'm
extremely comfortable i go up the aid
and i just have the bishop pair and a
position where white as nothing okay
so clean a six wasn't a good idea
so pony game got some new guys italic is
on grandma's of swat italic always
enjoyable to play them games always
interesting i left already
okay that doesn't it will make a be a
game there
yeah what are you guesses so how will
Chris tomorrow do in that event the
record and the Blitz any any predictions
you guys first in the jet
now yeah good yeah I had yeah but quite
often in the shows but not on at the
moment
yeah I would see what happens I think I
actually think that them that the field
is kind of okay firm game started Volo
with black okay yeah also feel it's kind
of okay i mean there are some some guys
in there I mean they're all very very
strong but some people who are think who
I think it would be in trouble against
they would you would definitely be in
trouble against Colin and MDL and those
are not playing and I mean okay hikaru
is also the favorite but I don't know
you think as probably lose some games on
time well maybe but it will definitely
it will be really interesting to see I
hope he's doing at least reasonably okay
that would make it much more much more
over on entertainment as people do quite
well I mean it's also funny to see him
maybe even making faces and so on the
typical Grisha might give him some
problems Chris Cook is not playing
though the freeing fly a case of Luke's
e8 erroneous in the tournament erroneous
can be very very strong in Rapids and
blitz but sometimes he also has problems
so yeah so so not so plain
okay let me stop this
I thought be sure I think we should is
not playing
okay so here we have a M kind of some
entire Bank Oh what not been only now
I'm taking and enter here to get
pressure against c3 yeah
PLT q he had the night is hanging i just
goes there who interesting
yeah let's activate the knight at the
end you wonder where we'll actually end
up
[Music]
and Bishop on b5 is kind of kind of
weird as you for also looked wrong to me
but what I'm doing here bringing the
knight to h6 is probably complete
complete nonsense
I know how this looks I want to bring it
to age six-foot come home what an
awfully played position what I did is
simply atrocious absolutely atrocious
Wow even f5 wouldn't work okay I put it
really far away from the action so I
will try to do stuff maybe still I mean
it takes really
I can give a chicken check I mean you
can check the exchange of course she
likes ISPs might be five in any case
okay
[Music]
just 96 very cool and you sell it
I just tried everything to get my stuff
activated no matter if it works or not
well that was the main thing
just selectivity time warning check my
blunder dead one it's probably roughly
equal now
now I cannot play for win check-check
just a draw
unless you want subscribe something Jen
don't see come on Quran is a repetition
actually truhair was a completely lost
game somehow I played this like a
complete idiot like from here I should
really be okay here somehow I should be
okay with that Nagi five to age six was
completely gaga
okay so a new game
and I have a Twitter what was I thinking
really really terrible game started any
massage place weird Trump lines now he
goes for support
[Music]
[Music]
how can you play this in one second you
will never understand that where people
play a super complicated position like
after six moves spent fifteen seconds I
don't understand check anyway okay so
how will we punish this nonsense tonight
I have 64 and on things are strong but
then I think this is this is just weird
and my ellicott broader tells us work in
progress it's currently current it's
currently am something else is having
priority I have to I have some problems
here with the technic
sorry guys I have to do something real
quickly my disk space is running short I
think this might influence the stream
[Music]
sorry I cannot play after delete a
couple of files here okay so now see
five and just take it probably check
okay so put some pressure here with that
diagonal and before I am
let's see what he does king of - no okay
I could actually take one g3 and that's
probably not correct though he just
wants eyes and some funny ideas save it
like take rook takes rook h1 check it
says something like that possible or
just Bishop d5 flexion in idea we cannot
move the light all that well like after
a three this is possible
Wow so b55 yeah what how can you I don't
get this person please absolutely
terrible in the opening and then place
like the genius yeah I really wonder how
this is sometimes happening okay so
would be one if I take only for twice
he's got 58 at the end we should be full
group Teague's I have to check on each
one
whatever
so check check
look h2 is actually a draw which is an
option because can I absolutely badly
have to go to the bathroom at the time
women there come on check glum are on I
might read whenever they have to go to
the bathroom I'm back in a second
you
yeah now I feel a lot better I just want
to check this I mean this must be a wind
right check is this I can take here yeah
and have a piece of yeah this is some
made threat yeah and it must be
something I maybe I should have done it
but I really had to go quite badly
okay so one more game and then it's we
already on for an hour game started Zoo
June 1960 I can go check check that
worked quite well before let me get to
this there I'm currently working on this
Q this will very likely end up as some
sort of Spanish opening ok t4 really
okay if I this not an issue you should
have three save some still yeah okay so
what also d5 is something that I would
be interested in it has to make some
kind of big money out of that and this
is not this is not looking all that
great the development is pretty bad
from black okay so take p5 you might
have to spend another move with Queen to
b6 it's pretty
you know just 94 maybe just the tech b5
my development is really not better here
no looks like b5 is more or less
dropping you can go look a8 and that
doesn't work so he just gives this up
let's just think about it for a moment I
mean if I take with this then c4 will be
probably in a weaker but maybe it's not
a big difference yeah we should be three
so that's it almost where is he going
quincy phone isn't that a second point
the second polish
yeah I would say that open he didn't go
all that well for black okay so I don't
want to give up this pawn where do I go
just back
chickens if I want to do that it's in
fact you have to be and this is actually
good yeah
no Bishop a6 okay I don't want to but
maybe this is the easiest way to do it
yeah hello - man we're gonna do Mona
still you probably not pronouncing it
correctly thanks for watching the games
okay so return to c8
maybe we should see form for special
94 Bishop c4 those things I'm actually
down long time which I find quite
surprising didn't feel to me like I was
spending that much time seems since I
did though
okay so Queen h4 no I create so I can
actually play
I mean queen g4 okay I could I could I
could play that okay so what's that
d6 is dropping he wants to take on h3 I
guess
I can still take this or this Bishop h3
happening now
my disguise was or anything else
taking too much time here
time warning they're very very bad that
I'm that I'm here this after this this
game allowing that much counter play is
really really awful you can see Luke
takes h3 now and that might be that
might work okay three maybe I'm still
okay look totally unnecessary
check unbelievable I'm such an invite
resigned I'm such an idiot damn like
you're winning
I'd like to move ten or so where like
here the position is already completely
winning yeah
amazing amazing gym tire what the heck I
don't want to play five minutes oops I
first have to have to check this a
little bit it still should be completely
winning but yeah would be 693 stone yeah
I mean I shouldn't even allow this this
crap yeah rook to h5 and stuff I didn't
like Bishop takes you 5 to this I really
didn't like seoulite a7 was winning l
okay but that looked weird
and a ticking the rook though if they
look at those quits and Bishop c5 is
right in there I mean it's totally over
hate to live with this game okay
I'm playing one more I don't think
anybody is starting a show right after
me so I can do one more
yes usually if somebody spends 20
seconds and it's lost just lost him and
then you allow all this nonsense I still
hate it but I did gain started who the
heck is cellphone
I don't know I don't know this guy so
let's see let's go to high rating this
is what I do
a seven here doesn't complete with the
green or what's the deal now I can
actually take a fall in this position
yeah I had this once and I forgot it I
forgot about it and at this this does
win that does win ah just a matter of
memory now
tinks Queen takes would be - yeah this
is winning for black but I I missed that
one stamp I was around I remember now
Prussia Zara swore to us if I played
against the move when a car's Aronian
came what would be a correct guess
percentage Wow
no idea it can there can be games where
you get quite well but there can also be
situations where you're where you don't
and where you don't get it at all
okay so what is happening here again
like f5 or something I don't remember
before text that
that is still a tough move at least for
me takes Knight takes is not convincing
10 then taking the rook and just f5 gem
just at five
okay if I take it I can take you for now
you would get guess more than just a few
recaptures in such a game I think the
percentage can be presented I mean I've
done commentary on ER on quite some
occasions and I think we often comes had
a pretty good guess percentage and it
should be it should be should be a
pretty much over
III is almost winning
this is not threatened actually
let me think about this for a moment we
see for union is a move
Quincy 14 d1 now settling III now
King Siwon take sticks okay
this now isn't there something direct
here take chick
[Music]
and I should see a win but I don't this
is probably enough but I was thinking I
should be something better check yeah
but it's good I look b1 it's pretty much
impossible to defend against
Queen c3 now I could have checked also
it would have been easier but okay
Queen c3 on this wonderful looks you on
it's enough plate resigned
yeah he stumbled right into that opening
tracks basically another trap that it's
a self trap that did something that I've
forgot once yeah somebody played this a
seven against me and I forgot this and
thought for ages and couldn't get it to
work and this is in fact really winning
this is this f5 event white is falling
apart
yeah so there was a nice one at the end
yeah I hope you enjoyed the show bit of
a weird time on Sunday but I think it
was a good decision to not collide with
the sing fields rapid and it
I also saying bye-bye now for almost for
almost four weeks actually I'll be back
on September 11th with the live show
almost four weeks I'll be on vacation
and yeah I hope you're always going in
the in four weeks I put and allowed to
video of course but it will be sometime
okay guys bye
[Music]